what if our why scares us um and and we
fear that people won't see it do we
abandon it or do we just go for it okay
so there's two thoughts there that are
worth unpacking
okay if other people don't see it okay
that's let's let's deal with that first
because i think that's a little
that's a little simpler if other people
don't
see it then the question is are we
showing it right
and so many of us all of us especially
at various times
we're all lying hiding and faking at
various points right
somebody asks a question you know that
makes us uncomfortable in a public forum
sometimes we agree to something we say
yes even though it's not true
because we just don't embarrass
ourselves we're very often inauthentic
plus we live in an instagram facebook
tech talkable world
we're all presenting ourselves and
curating ourselves as how we want to be
so we're really good at showing people
the kind of person we want to be
it's kind of ironic as well if you think
about relationships
um you know we present ourselves as the
as our best selves
but it's only really when our
vulnerabilities and insecurities are
revealed
can love exist um that's that magical
authenticity so i would argue that if
if the world doesn't see who you are you
know are there ways that you can share
it with the world
in a way that is inspiring um to them
and
and authentic to you um uh how you show
up
you know uh sometimes the clothes you
wear sometimes it's silly stuff
um you know i i always i would often
wear
bright brightly colored ties in college
i know a little nerdy
but um one because it sort of was a
reflection of my independence i didn't
dress like everyone else
but i it it also made people smile i
would catch them seeing my
my tie and it would make them smile and
and i liked that um
and so there are lots of little things
we can do personally um
to bring our why to life now what i'm
really interested in is what you said
andrea
when you said what if our why scares us
now if it's actually scary because it's
dangerous or difficult then maybe it's
not fully our why
if it scares us but because we are
afraid that others will judge us for
what it is
like this is truly who i am this is why
i wake up out of bed every morning
you know then then i think you have to
go for it now the question is do you
have to jump in the deep end
i think that's a question of your own
risk tolerance i think there's nothing
wrong with wading into the water
starting in the shallow end i mean think
about it look what i do for a living
inspire people that do the things that
inspire them like how corny and cheesy
is that
right like i'm fully aware of that when
i first started talking about it people
were like well that's
cheesy i'm like i know i know and so i
i but i still would do it and was it a
jumping in the deep end
no i would dip my toe and i would test
things out you know
and i would try things out not see how
it was received and sometimes it went
well and sometimes it didn't go well
i was learning to swim with my why as
basically was my why
floaties i was wearing why floaties
that's what i was doing
so yeah i think if it's if you if it
feels right because that's the test of a
why
you know does it feel right does it feel
like who i am does it give you chills or
goosebumps or does it make you well up
when you think about it does it excite
you
uh then it's probably accurate and yeah
then you gonna have to
uh at least get in the shallow end you
dip your foot in and try
try using it at certain places and as
you get more comfortable you'll learn to
[Music]
swim